let me start by saying this is something
that you already have heard but you
gotta find the hard my work is a deeper
meaning that you hook up this mic so now
I've told you guys before that Muriel is
a huge Disney plant flan
what the [ __ ] she's a huge Disney fan
and this year around is the 60th at
platinum diamond of enthusiam
anniversary so you guys already know
that mirror was already super hyped to
try to get me to go to this thing now I
told you guys this before not a huge fan
of Disneyland but I do enjoy it because
Mario likes it so I will go for her
two of the main attractions that you are
going to see at Disneyland or for the
60th platinum anniversary are the
fireworks and also the parade
just to put this in perspective for you
guys
Disneyland was [ __ ] packed and that's
probably one of the bigger reasons why I
hate going to theme parties because
everybody is touching you elbows all
about you people sweating fart in your
mouth that's the thing but this time
Disney I was a little bit different
because it wasn't just me and Muriel it
was also with sound normal which are now
my friends because I met them through
Muriel and you know yeah it was kind of
cool so a normal apparently had been
together for like four thousand [ __ ]
years I don't know how you guys did it
because I'm trying to kill Muriel
baby stop don't be mad at me I'm
preemptively apologizing for a joke that
I know that she won't find funny baby
now know recently what I've noticed that
marital has been doing to me a lot she
likes to like physically beat the [ __ ]
out of me well any of you out there have
actually been with a Korean girl they
seem to like to solve their problems
through a verbal abuse or to violence
we're because the way she shows
affection towards me is by harassing me
and guess what I'm all about equality
you harassed me I hope Rass you back
oh I'm good haha you always had this
thing that I hate is where she like
flicks my boobies and I already told her
multiple times if you touch my tits I'm
touching your tit too
oh my god it's different yeah it's
different because your sexual organs but
here's the thing
I don't like being touched out in public
on my titties so you don't touch mommy
go oh my god
that's not allowed either I have breasts
alone
I believe in equality freedom ooh
Beasley's - please yours it's only fair
I recently had a conversation with
people about what's the fascination with
Disney not for me Disney is just
something that was a part of my
childhood that I really enjoyed and
that's because it's like directly
connected to my child and I think for me
even though I like to live in childhood
or childlike whimsy you know I'm not in
love with the stuff that I wasn't
leveled when I was a kid is more of a
form of like nostalgia but Disney seems
to have this effect on people who no
matter if you're like a kid or an adult
you love it just as much as you did when
you were a child which to me is
fascinating remember that part in buting
the beast when you told Bill he couldn't
read you stupid I think people like Mary
or a lot of other adults like Disney so
much because you know as you grow up
you're kind of forced into being adult
and not in the sense that being an adult
is bad but it's kind of like that
childhood like quality that you had when
you were a kid is something that
shouldn't be lost especially the way
that you enjoy things I think when we
get older when we have to enjoy things
the first thing that we do before we
think about enjoying the situation is
critiquing it like we have to see what's
wrong with something first before we
tell ourselves that we like it
Disney doesn't have that effect you
enjoy it for what it is and you know for
me too you know I stay in the office a
lot or I stay at home and I'm writing
and thinking about new content that are
going to Muriel and going to Disneyland
with her is also a minor that's okay for
me to have fun every now and then like
my whole life isn't gonna crumble if I
don't if I don't work hard or something
you know but she's so cute let's be baby
no one's gonna love you
Oh
I